hola buenas tardes la información del
servicio copernicus creo que es
abrumadora y además concluyente
formadora porque es reportando una
anomalía
es la temperatura promedio global del
planeta de 1.25 grados centígrados y esa
cifra es tremendamente importante porque
significa que estamos muy cerca de
lograr desafortunadamente ese umbral que
nos hemos fijado como humanidad en el
acuerdo de parís que es tratar de
limitar el calentamiento global a 1.5
grados entonces imagínense el servicio
copérnico ya está reportando que la
anomalía va en 1.25 y por eso yo lo
llamo abrumador porque nos estamos
desviando nos estamos alejando de un
clima históricamente que había sido
benévolo que haya sido positivo para el
desarrollo de la humanidad y estamos
acercándonos a lo que se conoce como un
clima peligroso y también digo que son
datos concluyentes porque si bien el
2020 estuvo marcado por la pandemia y
por una profunda recesión económica eso
no significó
que las causas están asociadas al cambio
climático se detuvieran entonces por
supuesto también es concluyente saber
que la acción humana ha cambiado la
composición de la atmósfera y que el
cambio climático al contrario no se ha
detenido se ha venido acelerando y por
supuesto esta información de servicio
copérnico de la unión europea es
tremendamente preocupante muy bien pues
muchas gracias por su comunicación y su
análisis
oscar guevara él es especialista en
clima y biodiversidad de wwf